we don't talk anymore don't talk anymore
wir lassen uns besser etwas knapp netz
bekommen beim ein video und zwar gibt es
heute endlich nach wirklich sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr selbst erst sehr
sehr langer zeit
ok es waren vielleicht zwei wochen es
gibt auf jeden fall endlich wieder ein
neues musical i video und ich hab mir
heute wirklich was ganz besonderes
überlegt ich glaube das gibt es auch
wirklich noch nicht also das gibt es
wirklich noch nie auf youtube und zwar
geht es heute um die berühmtesten
musicals auf ganz musical der welt und
es wäre natürlich langweilig wenn ich
einfach nur meine musicals jetzt zeigen
würde
deswegen habe ich mir auch andere sehr
berühmten musicals rausgesucht die auch
fast so berühmt sind wie meine die auch
400 mal so berühmt sind die beiden us
wahrscheinlich ich habe etwas mit meinen
haaren angestellt die sind einfach
gerade so lang ich kann ihn nicht mehr
hoch machen deswegen hab ich mir gedacht
komm du gehst bald zum friseur macht ihr
die seite noch mal neue kurz machst hier
so einen strich und da sind strich und
legt sie einfach immer so nach hinten
also ich finds gewöhnungsbedürftig aber
ich hab mich jetzt schon ein bisschen
dran gewöhnen ich finde eigentlich ganz
coole könnt ihr eure meinung in die
comments schreiben auch wenn das video
eigentlich um haare geht sondern um
musicals ich will gar nicht eingeladen
bei ich sag mal 12.000 leider sagen dass
das warten jetzt kommen 12.000 like sind
sie drin weil 12.000 gibt es das nächste
musical video ihr habt ja irgendwie
bottrop und wir fangen sofort an mit
musical nummer eins was wahrscheinlich
schon sieben milliarden likes okay das
geht nicht auf jeden fall haben die alle
eine menge likes er das ist echt bei
manchen hab ich mir täter bekommen die
ganze menschen er so ich würde sagen wir
fangen erst mal mit
kann eigentlich jeder
aber nicht jeder kriegt nix dafür also
der rückwärtssalto am ende hat mir
wirklich sehr gefallen aber das war es
auch der rest war scheiße aber diese
nächte gleich aus die sehen einfach
komplett gleich aus fällt mir gerade auf
absolut ich versuche mal das ein oder
andere musical absolut ich versuchen wir
das ein oder andere musicali
nachzustellen ok waffen wir weiter mit
dem nächsten also ich glaube das musical
brauch ich kann das nie aussprechen also
ich glaube das musical gerade hatte so
ungefähr eine millionen likes oder knapp
eine million
aber es geht wird noch viel krasser also
wirklich krasser wir machen jetzt
erstmal mit einem weiter ich glaube das
hat er so 15 millionen das ist aber auch
schon verdammt krass ich finde das total
ich bin alex ich habe keinen plan was
ich hier aber vielleicht kriegt eine
million likes wie die gerade weil die
hatte glaube ich auch nicht so viel plan
was hier erzählt aber einfach mal ab
aber wirklich vollsten respekt ich meine
du machst alles richtig aber weiter zum
langweilig also für mich
den kenn ich der war gleich auch schon
mal irgendein video von mir drin
der hat auch irgendwie da so 14
millionen follower war oder so oder 12
video und keine ahnung also das war die
just right to grow up challenge und ich
finde diese challenge also diese just
waiting micro ob challenge im vergleich
zu meiner jazz metal exchange wirklich
nicht so gut
ich meine der nur drei bilder als er
klein war am anfang und ich hatte
einfach fünf oder sechs braucht sich gar
nicht aufregen
wir machen einfach mal weiter hat
irgendwie eine wunderkerze sollst du
mitmachen schöne stimme kann ich auch
wieder talk anymore
wir lassen uns besser als ich so alt war
wie deck konnte ich das genauso gut nur
dann bin ich im stimmbruch gekommen und
seitdem kann ich nicht mehr so gut
singen also ich will war wirklich früher
ein sehr sehr guter sänger hatte auch
wirklich sehr sehr viele auftritte vor
vielen menschen ich glaube mein größter
auftritt war in london vor 15.000
menschen da habe ich ein bisschen rum
geträllert so das war für mich damals
relativ ach so ja und dann habe ich halt
youtube entdeckt und seitdem mache ich
halt professionell youtube-videos falls
einfach viel cooler ist und so das
nächste musical hatte glaube ich so 1,7
millionen likes wir schauen
nach
der villa
habt ihr auch seine zunge geachtet ich
zeige euch jetzt mal wieder richtig geld
das kann ich besser auf jeden fall jetzt
kommen wirklich zu den krassesten
musicali auf ganz musicali das hat
unglaubliche jetzt haltet euch fest 4,5
millionen likes das ist finde ich so
heftig krass und das kommt natürlich von
lena in lisa lisa in lena wie auch immer
schauen wir mal kurz rein
ja das war es auch schon dafür kann man
auf jeden fall mal 4,5 millionen likes
da lassen
ich bin auf jeden fall richtig krass was
mir dieser app möglich ist und ich
könnte jeden einzelnen der damit so
krassen erfolge hat wirklich diesen
krassen erfolgen also macht weiter so
zieht euer ding durch und ich versuche
das ja auch irgendwie auch musicali
zurzeit ein bisschen so ab und zu mal
musical hochzuladen natürliches youtube
eine hauptplattform aber schaut auf
jeden fall mal bei unserem musical ja
komm vorbei von meiner freundin und mir
einmal aufs alex einfach mal kurz die
eigentlich eine checkliste ab ansonsten
hoffe ich natürlich dieses video hat
euch gefallen falls ja lass nach oben da
und checkt auf jeden fall mein snapshot
of war ich in letzter zeit nicht so
aktiv aber jetzt auf jeden fall wieder
gerne ins netz wir sehen uns dann morgen
wieder ein video um 19 uhr
ihr seid dabei ich freue mich auf euch
leute
wir sehen uns peace